hi my name is gay Grossman I'm one of
the founders of ad cy5 org and I came
about being a founder of a be cy5 org
when my daughter was diagnosed with that
gene mutation and what I'm going to talk
to you about today is how using IPS
cells has given us the ability to move
science forward for our daughter who has
the disease ad cy5 related dyskinesia
and also other children who have been
diagnosed with this mutation on that on
that gene
so I'm going to give you a little bit of
an overview of the 21 years we've had
our daughter Lily is 21 years old she
was undiagnosed until she was 15 years
old and so I'm going to go over a little
bit of what our journey has been like
trying to find a diagnosis and then
using whole genome sequencing which is
what took us to the diagnosis and the
challenges that we've had since getting
the diagnosis through sequencing tough
stem cells has benefited us in this
process and then what we're doing now to
use those stem cells to get us closer to
a treatment for her children and other
adults who have been diagnosed so going
back to 1997 which is when Lily was born
we everything was going along pretty
easily and we've been married for a
while his first pregnancy we didn't have
any issues and Lily was born without any
complications we brought her home and
within the first year we noticed that
she was having some trouble
she wasn't pulling up in her crib she
she kind of looked like she didn't
prefer to sit up she would kind of roll
back in a controlled way and she could
hold the board book over her face and
turn the pages so when we saw her having
the ability to do things like changing
those pages we figured that maybe there
wasn't anything challenging her but as
time went on through that first year we
started noticing that she would fatigue
quickly especially when she was in
warmer temperatures and she seemed to
have sensitivities to a lot of different
food and she had that bad balance she
could stand on her feet and hold on in
furniture walk but she wasn't able to
ever really let go so because of all
these challenges that she was having our
life quickly turned into something that
looks like this we started taking her
all over the country to different
facilities who might have some answers
for why she was having these challenges
and by the time we did by the time Lily
was eight years old we had already taken
her to over 40 specialists all over the
country we you know we were getting to
be pretty desperate as parents we were
looking at things with conventional
medicine holistic medicine we saw some
very alternative doctors we really tried
anything that physicians or any
healthcare provider suggested to us
and as we started doing a lot of testing
with on Lily we were given different
diagnoses as time went on when she was
about a year and a half it was the first
time that we were able to convince
physicians that we really wanted to get
a brain scan and see what was happening
inside and when her brain scan came back
normal we were told that she probably
had a very slight diagnosis of cerebral
palsy and we didn't have that diagnosis
long because as we moved on and she
started to get older and she developed
tremors that looked like seizures but we
found out weren't seizures was a normal
EEG but we moved on from those diagnoses
pretty quickly into mitochondrial
disease and a lot of a lot of scientists
and researchers today will tell you that
perhaps ABC y 5 related dyskinesia is is
in fact a mitochondrial disease but back
in the late 90s mitochondrial disease
could not be as made as specific as a
can be today with the different genes
that were able to identify but we didn't
really have a treatment for Lily other
than giving her your typical
mitochondrial disease cocktail and that
was basically to keep her healthy to
keep her immune system up and the base
the most important symptom that we were
trying to alleviate for her was the
tremors that she would have and when she
was a baby this was just mostly during a
little bit during the night it wasn't
very it wasn't very hard and it wasn't
very often but as she started to get
older and her body started to get bigger
these tremors continue to escalate in
severity and also frequency so we tried
all kinds of different things as we were
going around the country meeting these
doctors we tried different medications
whether they were supplements or
prescription weed
try epilepsy medications to try to help
alleviate the movements that she was
having we took her off of wheat corn soy
dairy and sugar and some of these things
did make a difference a little bit but
they still did not stop the movements
that she was having during the day and
into the evening and night time we we
even went to the extreme of having
things in our home tested because we
just couldn't we couldn't really put in
point where this trouble was coming from
we even through all the testing that we
were done with Lily everything was
coming back with normal results
so as she was getting older this picture
shows her and about kindergarten she was
able to walk with a walker it was
difficult for and she was still having a
hard time keeping up her muscle weakness
was pretty severe the involuntary
movements continued and we started
having her use a laptop in school rather
than having to struggle with reading and
writing
she was always cognitively typical
always did well in school but this
physical challenge that she had with her
balance and her strengths and the
tremors that she had just you know
really was prominent in her life
you
so as you can imagine we went through a
variety of testing with her and it
started with a simple blood test and
quickly escalated into more invasive
testing things like nerve conduction
testing muscle biopsies nerve biopsy
skin biopsies MRIs every few years and
every single test that we put Lily
through would come back normal and you
know was obvious at this time that
something was not right and that these
challenges were not going to go away and
as a matter of fact they were just
getting worse as she got older
so if she got older and she was probably
about she was probably in about sixth or
seventh grade we were really in a
holding pattern because nothing was
giving us clues about what could be
wrong and you know she wasn't gaining
ground she wasn't really losing ground
but she was up constantly through the
night and if she was up you know five to
six times the night that was actually a
good night for us and a lot of people
asked us you know what were those nights
like and it's kind of you know I guess
you can think about when you're when
your child has the flu and they're up
all night and you do it for maybe two
two nights and then two things seem to
get better but for us she was up with
these tremors and we call them tremors
but they're really more like seizures
and she was up with these you know like
I said on a good night five to six times
a night and sometimes as they would
progress and if she would get more tired
the severity of them would increase and
sometimes she would be up every five
minutes
when she would wake up in pain she was
aware and you know just thrashing in
pain with these movements so that a lot
of times it happened during the daytime
but it definitely happened every night
for 15 years and it was a very difficult
time for all of us because obviously our
whole household was up with her trying
to alleviate the misery for her
abig treatments and that seemed to help
a lot but it never made them go away
and again the diet changing helped but
it never made things go away she would
be put into the hospital a couple times
throughout the year and mostly that
would be because the tremors would get
so bad that she just couldn't sleep and
she would be up so many nights that the
more she was up the worse the tremors
got and the worse the tremors got the
more she was up so we would get in these
vicious cycles and there was just really
no way to break it and so we would admit
her to the hospital and they would give
her something to actually put her to
sleep and as her body would rest it
would kind of reset itself but this was
you know this was a couple times a year
that we would have to do this she'd also
have to be hospitalized if she got any
kind of flu she just didn't seem to have
the reserve to be able to fight
something like that and we we asked
about whole genome sequencing when she
went to have her her muscle and nerve
biopsy in 2007 but as you might remember
we didn't really know what to do with
results them and you know some people
would argue that even today we don't
know what to do with a lot of the
results with whole genome sequencing but
we just wanted to know we figured that
was the best way that we could find an
answer for her with a diagnosis
so through this time we we just tried to
accommodate for her and make things as
as easy as we could for her in school
and we decided when she was going into
middle school to get her a power chair
so that she could keep up and change
classes and physically keep up with her
peers just moving about school
I think that it's important to note that
her weakness probably increased
significantly when she got the power
chair because of her sitting and not
using a walker but at that time we
didn't know what Lily's future held and
her success was found through school and
so we felt that providing her with that
even though it would perhaps cause more
limitations in her future it was
important for us to feel that success
that she could through school
the other thing that we did was we
started keeping track our on our own of
the sleeping disturbances and this slide
is often used by some of the researchers
who speak about ABC Y 5 related
dyskinesia and this is every dot on
there is showing you a time that lily
has gotten up at night and this is over
a year and a half of of nights and what
we did was we found an app on our iPad
and it's actually a pregnancy app for
contractions and what we would do is
every time she would awaken we would hit
the button when we leave our room and go
into her room and help her and once she
got settled back to sleep we would go
back into our room and turn it off
so we were able to see where these
pockets were of when she was sleeping
really badly and when she was just
sleeping simply badly but it was really
the first time that anyone had collected
any kind of data and we you know we just
decided as a family we needed to start
collecting data so we could help the
researchers see the severity of the the
awakenings at night
so we were fortunate enough to be able
to take part in the idiopathic diseases
of man study that was run by Scripps
translational science Institute and this
is when Lily was 15 years old she was
luckily admitted into this study and we
were able to get the results from this
but when we were going through it we
went through another study at the same
time which was the emotional aspect of
having your whole genome sequenced and I
specifically remember one of the
questions that they asked Lily when we
were we had already had our blood drawn
and we were waiting for the results and
one of the questions that the
researchers wanted to know was you know
what if what if something really bad was
found and something that was terminal
and that they could do nothing about and
Lily was never afraid of that and
actually I wasn't either it was I think
it's important for physicians to know
who are who have the ability to offer
whole genome sequencing to families that
actually finding out bad news like that
is something that you can process and
you can move forward with but not having
a diagnosis is actually more difficult
and Lily's biggest fear of going through
this process and then not having any
diagnosis at the end that was actually
more upsetting to her to think about
then getting something back that would
be you know something someone would
consider to be very challenging
so when when we did get the results back
from the whole genome sequence II we
were given two genes that had mutations
on them one is the ABC Y 5 gene and the
other sadoc 3 gene and one they told us
the ABC y5 gene they could possibly do
something about the Dok 3 gene was
something that they didn't have any data
on as of yet and both of these genes are
responsible for balance and coordination
and they've been described to me as kind
of the gears on a bike and if the gears
don't work the whole bike's not going to
go so when we were given this
information we were also told that she
would have a normal life expectancy
which that was big news to us because
that was not something that we were we
were not given that before she had the
diagnosis so the first thing that we did
was we were able to take Lily off of all
of her seizure medications which
obviously you can imagine would be
debilitating during the day as they made
her tired and they just kind of made
things a little bit better with the
sleeping but they never alleviated
everything fully so we were able to
start a drug called Diamox and that
enables Lily to sleep for about nine
days in a row nine nights and we had not
slept that you know we hadn't slept a
full night in 15 years so that was
absolutely life-changing after the nine
days and nights we started seeing the
sleep fall away and the tremors were
coming back and we were able to adjust
the medication enough and we've also
added tetra Ben Azim and Lily now sleeps
all night she doesn't have any issues
sometimes stress will bring things back
for a week but she quickly gets back on
track and
we've been able to you know change
things pretty significantly for her so a
lot of people have said to us well you
know she's still in a wheelchair and
what's the benefit but I can tell you
that sleeping and being able to sleep
all night
is a huge benefit and life-changing and
you think being in a wheelchair is bad
it's actually worse if you can't sleep
at night so just to let you know Lily's
life changed she was able to we could
take her and stay in hotel as you can
imagine we couldn't stay in a hotel
before with her being up all night
crying and we took her to Paris in
London for her graduation Christmas
birthday combination gift and we were
able to stay in hotel there with her and
she could see all kinds of beautiful art
that she loves and she was really able
to experience those cities fully she
also is now away at college and although
she needs 24/7 care she is you know as
I've explained cognitively typical and
she's been able to do things that we
never imagined that she would be able to
do so after this diagnosis we shared our
story with a lot of different places
that asked us to and the main reason
that we share our story so much is that
we want to give other families hope and
we want people to understand what we
went through and what other families
might be enduring and they don't know
that they have this mutation and if
anybody can go online in Google Ad cy5
they will find us and they can connect
with us quickly and we can hopefully get
them in contact with a specialist who
can help them with the sleep issues and
we can also let them know that know the
science that we're doing
so now on to other things you get your
diagnosis and you think your Odysseys
over and actually you're just beginning
a whole new journey because now you have
to figure out what to do with that
information that you have
so after sequencing what we did was we
kind of assessed where where lily was
and with the sleeping everything was
much better but whole genome g-code
whole genome sequencing doesn't always
give you a treatment it might give you
the answer it might give you some ideas
but it might not give you the answers
that you need to completely be relieved
of your diagnosis and even though
everything is better for Lily a lot of
things are better there's still things
that she has to endure and the reason
that we want to continue the science she
still gets a monthly IVIG treatment
which is an infusion that is actually
ten hours long she has it five hours on
one day and five hours on the next she
takes an orphan drug every day that
twice a day it's over six thousand
dollars a month
she has 24/7 care and she you know
continues to be reliant on wheelchairs
and other durable medical equipment and
you know things that help her get
through her day
so what we've done is we've we've
started a DC y5 org and we did that
shortly after a diagnosis and the main
purpose of that is to support other
families we also want to be able to
provide a place for researchers and
clinicians to go if they have a
diagnosis or interesting in the science
we want to be able to give them a place
to look and see what's happening and be
able to connect with each other and what
we did as a family is we put all this
together so that we can make it as easy
as possible for researchers and
clinicians to get the information use
the information in order to help other
parents
so we're working together to really
leverage technology and put things
together ourselves so that we can help
the researchers do what they do best and
what we don't know how to do as parents
so we have put together a family meeting
where we were able to get clinicians and
researchers together in one room and we
could put seven different families in
front of them one at a time and they
could see them one after the other and
compare and contrast and take notes and
we've been able to work with these
clinicians to put together different
ideas so that we can start doing a
Natural History study and and others and
other science in order to move toward
treatment so when our when the people
that we've worked with before Lily was
diagnosed it was mostly institutions
around the country now the connections
that we have are much more people who
are in the science field and technology
and are doing things that are moving
towards science and treatment
we share our story with anyone who will
listen to us speak and we I do a lot of
public speaking and I will speak to
anyone from a local organization who's
just interested in science and what's
happening today to the different
universities in our area and different
corporations who are involved in science
just to let them know the benefits that
we've had by learning about science
including people who work with science
in our disease
so through this Lily was she was the
first one to be diagnosed with the
mutation that encompassed her whole body
and since then we've been able to
connect with over 80 families that have
since gotten the same diagnosis that
Lily has and in the papers there are
over 300 people who have been identified
in different databases and because this
is such a small population we have taken
it upon ourselves to put together the
science and really try to make some
breakthroughs with this and one of the
things that we've been doing is the IPSC
project and we were the first ones as a
small rare disease organization to put
together a stem cell project for the
ultra rare disease community we've been
able to get 13 lines of patients who
have the actual ad cy5 mutation and also
31 parents and siblings who are not
affected by the mutation and these cells
are available through choreo and what
this means is that scientists have
access to these at a much lower price
and they're available all over the world
and the impact that we have for you know
for the scientists is if we can provide
these IPSC to them rather than saying to
them we can provide blood or skin and
then they in turn have to turn them into
these stem cells it completely lowers
the price for the scientists they now
can get them as stem cell lines they
know that they can get more than one
stem cell line to compare them we have
been able to take this project and offer
the results to scientists so that they
can abbreviate the work and the funding
that they need to move the project
forward we're also able to offer this
with no IT reach back conditions so they
can go ahead and do the work and get
credit for what they come up with and
what this does is it it enables the you
know the true precision medicine efforts
it's taking the IPS sees of these of
these patients and giving the scientists
the resources that they need to move
forward toward a treatments
so the next step that we're taking as a
foundation is reaching out to different
scientists and letting them know that
these stem cell lines are available
we're also putting together a Natural
History study so that we can have
retrospective and prospective data on
all these patients and using different
sensors that so that we can collect the
information for patients who are still
not sleeping well at night and educating
different people who go to conferences
about AV cy5 related dyskinesia and just
letting them know about the projects
that we have put together and that we
have available and that they can
participate in and then we're also
working to identify funding and and we
are funding a researcher right now to
continue his work so that we make sure
that the treatment is coming faster than
it might have if we weren't putting
these things together
so we we've been able to abbreviate the
time and also the money for these
researchers they can just get right down
to work with the IPSC cells
so these are our next steps as an
organization of what we plan to do with
these cells that we were able to get
we're going to be differentiating them
doing RNA sequencing and reviewing
different proposals for model organisms
and then as I discussed doing the
Natural History study so that we can
collect as much information that week as
we can about the disease so that we can
forward that on to researchers so that
they can utilize the information
there are a lot of benefits to having
these stem cells it's been able to help
us attract different researchers because
we already have this tool for them to
use and we're we're seeing benefits
already many of you have seen the movie
with John Travolta about the boy in the
bubble and you know that was something
that was a debilitating disease in the
past and now if that mutation is shown
to be present for a newborn baby they
can get the treatment and they have a
tough couple of years of building that
immune system but once they build it
there they're cured from the disease and
this is the kind of thing that we have
in our mind for the future for Lily and
for other children and adults who have
been diagnosed with AV cy5 related
dyskinesia
so people always ask you know where is
Lily now and what is she doing she's a
senior in college she goes to Whittier
College up by Los Angeles it's a small
liberal arts school easy to get around
because of the nice small campus and
it's been great for Lily to take part in
the campus she's majoring in political
science and hasn't has will have a minor
in English and she's very involved in
the student body she was in the Student
Senate she was a member of a sorority
and she is now a football and basketball
cheerleader so she is you know very
happy there and very interested in the
science and we have conference calls she
wants to be on the call to listening to
hear what's happening and it really it
gives her hope and it lets her know that
she is a pioneer in the science and that
everything that that we put together as
an organization we put together for her
will someday affect positively other
people who are affected with not only
her mutation but other mutations because
we believe that anything that we're
learning about you know through using
these stem cells will somehow benefit
everybody in rare disease and that is
our goal is to move treatment forward
for everybody
if you're interested in contacting me
about questions my email is Gigi ro SS
ma n @ ad cy5 org and you can also
either google Lily or myself and read a
lot of different stories about our
family and what we have accomplished and
what we hope to accomplish and if you
have any questions then I welcome you to
email me at any time and I will get back
to you but thank you so much for your
time and good luck with the research
that you plan to do okay